civil wars here and since we've already
done all the new Captain America movies
let's travel back to 1990 and pull a VHS
out of the honest trailer vault
you've already sat through Marvel's
pathetic attempts at a live-action
spider-man Thor daredevil and Punisher
but Marvel's not done embarrassing
themselves yet in a movie so bad it
wasn't even released in theaters Captain
America the one you'll rent from
Blockbuster Video it's 1990 and DC rules
the cinemas now laugh while a desperate
Marvel scrambles to get it together in
this rushed attempt to catch up with
Batman and Superman critical and
box-office dominance
it may not be Superman you've got that
right the son of reclusive author JD
Salinger stars as Steve Rogers for some
reason a California beach bum pretending
to have polio but when he volunteers to
be sapped with an experimental
flashlight he'll become Captain America
a soldier who isn't a captain here's a
little more time to practice and spends
very little time in America buongiorno
uh speaking this the president has been
kidnapped we're taking a stand on the
only issue that matters in the 90s the
environment we're gonna have to find
millions of new jobs for the people who
make disposable plastics toxins
household pesticides if we don't take
this medicine now we'll all die now
after spending 40 years frozen in a tiny
snow bank cap let's deal with the
culture shock of today's America I guess
they didn't have VCRs of where you were
and save the president from the
extremely lumpy Italian red skull and
his extremely Italian henchman 18 whoo
Baba Captain America
Mamma Mia what a piece of crap you
thought Marvel's 1979 Captain America
was bad you ain't seen nothing yet
stare at Captain America's rubber ears
and wonder why does it have than America
of rubber ears and they just you know
cut a hole for the actors human ears
thrill as his super strength and shield
throwing powers return Plus things you
never thought you'd see the captain do
like
run away run away I'm a little bike hide
and pretend to be nauseous so he can
steal someone's car
would you please pull over the car I am
going to get sick
are you okay yep twice could you pull
over for a minute I think I'm gonna be
sick so gear up for another crapped-out
Marvel superhero movie full of terrible
acting mr. president thanks ridiculously
fake stuns
fight scenes shot in complete darkness
and action sequences so bad they either
feel like they were shot in slow motion
or cut together by sam raimi on speed
man they'll never get this character
right unless DC buys the rights starring
the captain in the Rye Regenstein budget
meg Ryan and the cast of a Christmas
Story
huh that's weird crapped in America yeah
this movie wasn't great but what if they
teamed up with Eric Kramer's Thor Lou
Ferrigno's Hulk and Dolph Lundgren's
Punisher they could totally do an
Avengers movie a really awful Avengers
movie Oh Who am I kidding just hanging
up Marvel DC rules be sure to subscribe
for more honest trailers hey screen
junkies want to see the Russo brothers
give their epic commentary to our honest
trailer for the Winter Soldier then
click the box or the description below
to see them take our trailer team to
task and give behind-the-scenes insights
on the making of the film check it out
and if you'd like to match wits against
the screen junkies team check out our
summer box of escape for a chance to win
a free year of screen junkies plus and
other great prizes go to screen junkies
comm slash box-office game to enter and
read the Official Rules or check out the
description below enter today and you
might wear the summer box-office crown I
am a world before I am a man I was a
creature before I could stand I will
remember before I forget save is I dare
you I double dare you
soozee sits in a shoeshine shop where
she said she shines where she shines she
sits
I have the store my lord the first and
the last it's a long way to the top if
you want a rock and roll she was my
world
and you took her from me